I [ __ ] by the way talk about being
fat I've worked out so hard okay I
crushed six ice cream sandwiches last
night you ever done that [ __ ] you ever
done anything like that you have have
you okay okay actually that makes me
feel much [ __ ] better six bro okay so
you haven't then my producer [ __ ]
literally lied to me in this small room
you ever done anything like that he goes
yeah I said six he says no which is it
bro I [ __ ] ate six and I and you know
what dude I chose to be done
I could have eight nine [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's it I could never stop eating you
know how people are like oh how about
portions what huh portions huh how much
did you make that's mine
what are you talking about portions yo
do you know how many times I haven't
eaten other people's meals that weren't
done to only when I'm in a professional
setting if I'm with a girl if I'm with
my mom or brother gimme that chill dude
what are you talking about portions how
much did you make dude my uncle's this
way too
my dad's not this way my dad elite a
portion the [ __ ] my brother will eat a
portion of the portion what are you
trying to fit in a swimsuit what is your
mind doing give me all the taste bro I'm
full here but this [ __ ] feels jolly up
here still my tongue is dancing through
that flavor is dancing around my mouth
yeah I'm working on a [ __ ] I'm
working on filling up a toilet bowl in
my bottom section but that food is
having a [ __ ] mark
Gras party dude the pasta in my mouth is
yelling at the sauce telling it to show
its tits that's how much I want in my
[ __ ] mouth it's throwing a 40th
over-the-hill birthday party in my mouth
and I'm not done inviting people can my
friends come yes are they tasty
give me that two portions come on dude I
mean really I eat to like feel obviously
look at me I take I try to take care of
myself I obviously understand you know
I'm lucky I got a fast metabolism but I
also work out very hard ok but bro I eat
sometimes till I feel you ever eat so
much that you feel so gross where you
feel like you know what would top it off
just getting a dirty suck you know what
I'm talking about
if I was if I ate so much I was so fat
that I just sat here and got a dirty
suck like after I [ __ ] buy some
[ __ ] like you know some [ __ ] like
a lawyer just a dirty suck from a female
lawyer you know that's how [ __ ] much
I eat I eat so much that I would just
sit in a curvy position on my couch with
my [ __ ] tummy out just getting a
dirty sock from a lawyer bro that's how
much I eat Nick naked all postman by the
way [ __ ] post mates do it all over eats
it and they'll [ __ ] show up to my
house I'll eat all this [ __ ] with my
naked is [ __ ]
dick flopping around and then just
imagine getting a dirty suck by the way
I'm not even horny it's just about the
eating it's about the eating it makes
you feel better that you ate so much
you're like if I just gonna dirty suck
and watch [ __ ] like the strain on TV
and start season in the middle of season
three just so much disrespect going on
just disrespect and everything I'll eat
I'll leave all this [ __ ] disrespect my
body I'll get a dirty suck and
disrespect my partner and then watch
this strain start with season three and
disrespect the producers and actors that
have worked so hard
creating the moment up until season
three but just start in the middle in
the middle of a show in the middle of
[ __ ] season 3 episode 5 in the middle
of it just [ __ ] we're all of a sudden
where they're like where they're like
well I don't know what to do now that
we're surrounded and you just start
watching imagine getting a dirty suck in
you age seven ice cream sandwiches and
some pasta it's good to have nights like
that man I don't mean to be so [ __ ]
inspiring but it's good to have nights
like that you've got to live a little
one time I saw the rock in an Instagram
video how he was there's like I never
heard in and out but I took my cast
members to in-and-out and he drove
through and they were like hey it's the
rock and he got the burgers and he
handed the burgers over for his [ __ ]
cast mates and he didn't eat the burgers
I know I know he has cheat days I've
seen it but bro if you drive through in
and out you get a [ __ ] burger be
disrespectful 37
Darrin isaque dirty sock